vous êtes au québec pour une visite
éclair quelques jours pour nous parler
dans votre prochaine tournée en 2019
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour vous de
revenir dans un travail ce que j'aimais
beaucoup
d'abord l'attachement que j'ai au québec
est très fort depuis toujours depuis la
première fois que je suis venue tout
simplement parce que j'avais écrit un
spectacle j'avais dit on peut pas savoir
où on va si on sait pas d'où on vient et
j'arrive à québec et je vois sur les
plaques d'immatriculation des voitures
je vois je me souviens ça m'avait
beaucoup beaucoup marqué que des gens
décident de mettre je me souviens sur
une plaque d'immatriculation et c'était
et et ensuite c'est la première fois
dans sa va faire 35 ans que je viens ici
que je vais aller jouer en dehors de
montréal et de québec parce que le
québec sépaq que montréal et québec
c'est tout à fait excitant pour moi je
fais ce que je veux juger plus d'entravé
l'hypocrisie le mensonge plus rien je
fais ce que je veux
comment ça se passe à 8 e tournée au
québec pour vous en profitez pour avoir
deux vieux potes ici bas ici quand
j'arrive avant d'arriver ou dès que je
descends de l'avion
j'appelle michel barrette j'appelle jean
michel anctil tout de suite parce que
c'est mes 2 mai deux piliers ils sont
ils sont indissociables de ma vie ici
mais ils sont cédés camarades que j'ai
rencontrés sur scène michel barrette ya
plus longtemps que jean michel et il
s'est passé sur scène quelque chose de
rare humainement artistiquement une
entente parfaite il vous êtes vraiment
dreux pouvait me faire quelque chose de
drôle mais c'est comme ça que je savais
ce n'est pas prévu - moi je suis drôle
parce qu'il ya une vraie on est comme
des musiciens de jazz et ont fait un
boeuf ensemble c'est rarissime vous
savez c'est très rare tu es d'où toi moi
ça durera plus rageant vous avez
jusqu'au 6 mai chicoutimi mais c'est ma
fille chicoutimi chicoutimi nord ou
shooting notre beau spectacle comme
toute ma vie encore plus rêver shell
bouge notre avis une super carrière des
enfants plein de projets plein la tête
que voulez vous de plus qu'à quoi
rêvez-vous encore on meurt si on rêve
pas c'est vrai que si on dort pas aux
moeurs et on meurt pas parce qu'on dort
pas parce qu'on rêve pas ces
scientifiques
donc il faut dormir pour pouvoir rêver
et pour pouvoir continuer à vivre
on peut pas vivre sans les rêves on peut
pas continuer à vivre sans rêver qu'est
ce que le monde serait si les rêveurs
n'existait pas qu'est-ce-qui ce qu'est
ce qui se passerait la north avait
d'ailleurs j'adore j'aimerais vivre
comme toi je te jure
et je crois que comme j'ai dit dans mon
spectacle la vie qu'on rêve si on la
rêve très très fort à la fin la vie
qu'on rêve ou la vie
et même si parfois ça devient un
cauchemar le jeu en vaut la chandelle
tu rentres à 3h et 3h30 du matin tudor
jusqu'à 4 heures de l'après midi c'est
une merveille
quand tu te lèves d'ailleurs c'est ton
corps qui se lève ton cerveau il reste
dans le matelas et futurs il avait 66
ans pensez-vous à ce niveau il avait
trompé j'ai 26 ans mais pas ou moins
j'aurai arrête
bah oui bien sûr que j'ai un jour je
vais arrêter
bien sûr j'ai la chance contrairement
aux sportifs de haut niveau d'avoir
déclaré adam un carrières longues
physiquement je m'entretiens franchement
trouvé que je fais 66 ans non on est
d'accord donc mais je vais m'arrêter
j'ai regardé la faire
je vous conte une affaire de même il
veut oui tu dis ça moi je sais écouter
plein de fois
en terminant vous avez un projet de film
avec michel bart oui où en est ce projet
on a besoin d'un scénariste
alors j'en appelle à ceux qui nous
regardent jeu je n'ai pas le temps de
l'écrire parce que vous avez compris je
n'arrivais même pas à fournir tout ce
que je dois faire
michel est très occupé on a besoin d'un
scénariste
on veut faire ce film ici on veut faire
ce film sur ces deux père surprotecteur
avec leurs deux filles
voilà bon prenez un petit peu de temps
et écrivez-nous ce film je vous jure
vous n'allez pas le regretter
on va beaucoup rire on va beaucoup
pleuré on va voilà ça serait un cadeau
pour michel barrette et moins magnifique
sur la pas le temps mais c'est notre
faute je comprendrais que vous fassiez
pas monsieur dame
michel boujenah merci mille fois je
faisais moi c'est moi à chicoutimi a pas
de bab el bared balle est à chicoutimi
tous les gens qui s'appellent tremblay